A GROWING TRAVEL SECTOR.
AINSLEY: THANK YOUS, LYDIA.
STEVE: SO MANY BUSINESSES ARE
ARE STILL SUFFERING FROM THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF LOCKDOWN.
>> IT’S BEEN A REALLY TOUGH TIME
FOR THE INDUSTRY.
IT’S BEEN FOR A WHILE.
WE’VE DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
GET READY.
>> SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT A THEY’VE
DONE, IT’S UNTHINKABLE AND, TO
ME, IT’S A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> WE’RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE A
DOLLAR HERE X IT’S VERY
DIFFICULT.
>> I KNOW I CAN SPEAK FOR ALL
THESE OTHER RESTAURANTS ALSO,
WE’RE DONE.
STEVE: BUT DON’T TELL THAT TO
THE L.A. TIMES WHICH CLAIMS
LOCKDOWNS DIDN’T HARM THE
ECONOMY AT ALL.
LOOK AT THAT HEADLINE RIGHT
THERE.
TO REACT, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AND OPINION COLUMNIST FOR THE
HILL, JOE CONCHA.
GOOD MORNING.
>> HAPPY THURSDAY, STEVE, HOW WE
DOING?
STEVE: WE’RE GOING OKAY,
ALTHOUGH IT’S PRETTY CLEAR THE
L.A. TIMES IS IN LA LA LAND.
WE JUST HEARD FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESS PEOPLE THAT THE LOCK
AREDOWNS STRANGLED THEM, AND YET
THIS WRITER’S TRYING TO SAY NO
HARM TO THE ECONOMY.
>> YEAH.
LOOK, THIS IS AN OPINION PIECE,
IT’S NOT A NEWS STORY, AND
OPINIONS ARE LIKE -- I CAN’T SAY
THAT.
IT’S LIKE DERRIERES, EVERYBODY
HAS ONE, WE’LL PUT IT THAT WAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE STUPID THEST
THINGS I’VE EVER READ BECAUSE IT
IGNORES HARD DATA AND NUMBERS.
LET’S LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, SHALL
WE?
IN CALIFORNIA THE UNEMPLOYMENT
IS CURRENTLY AT 8.3%.
LET’S COMPARE THAT TO A STATE
THAT’S BASICALLY BEEN OPEN FOR
THE LAST YEAR IN FLORIDA UNDER
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WHERE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS 4.7%.
SO YOU’RE WITH TALKING ABOUT A
BIG SHIFT THERE.
OVERALL, STEVE, 8 MILLION JOBS
HAVE BEEN LOST SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN.
WE HAVEN’T GOTTEN THOSE BACK
YET.
SO TO SAY THAT COVID LOCKDOWNS
HAVE ACTUALLY NOT HURT THE
ECONOMY, PARTICULARLY IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE A THIRD OF THE
RESTAURANTS THERE HAVE BEEN
CLOSED OR TWO-THIRDS OF
RESTAURANT WORKERS LOST THEIR
JOBS AT ONE POINT, IT IS A
PROFOUNDLY STUPID ARGUMENT TO
MAKE.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
I’M SURE EVERY ONE OF THOSE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THAT WE
SPOKE TO AND HAVE SPOKEN TO
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU.
JOE, MEANWHILE, I DON’T KNOW IF
YOU SAW, BUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WAS AT THE
GRADUATION FOR THE COAST GUARD
CADETS YESTERDAY, AND AFTER HE
MADE -- HE DELIVERED, JOE BIDEN
DELIVERED THE EXACT SAME LINE
THAT RONALD REAGAN DELIVERED TO
THE EXACT SAME AUDIENCE ABOUT 30
YEARS EARLIER.
BUT AS YOU’RE ABOUT TO SEE,
WE’RE GOING TO PUT THE SOUND
BITES BACK TO BACK.
AS YOU CAN SEE, ONE PERSON DID
IT AND GOT A BIG LAUGH, AND THE
OTHER PERSON WAS SHOCKED AT THE
RECEPTION.
HERE THEY ARE, PRESIDENTS REAGAN
AND BIDEN.
>> MY COAST GUARD AIDES HAVE
BEEN EXCELLENT.
ONE WITH OF THEM TAUGHT ME THAT,
AND I QUOTE, THE COAST GUARD IS
THAT HARD NUCLEUS ABOUT WHICH
THE NAVY FORMS IN TIME OF WAR.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT YOU’LL
ENJOY EDUCATING YOUR FAMILY
ABOUT HOW THE COAST GUARD IS,
QUOTE: THE HARD NUCLEUS AROUND
THE NAVY FORMS IN TIMES OF WAR.
YOU ARE A -- YOU’RE A REALLY
DULL CLASS.
[LAUGHTER]
I MEAN, COME ON, MAN.
STEVE: OKAY.
REAGAN WAS A TELEVISION
PERFORMER AND A MOVIE STAR.
IT’S ALL ABOUT THE PRESENTATION.
IT’S ALL ABOUT THE DELIVERY, AND
I GUESS -- HOW WOULD YOU GRADE
THE TWO?
>> INTERESTING.
REAGAN MADE THAT SPEECH IN 1988.
THAT WAS THE SAME YEAR THAT JOE
BIDEN RAN FOR PRESIDENT AND HAD
TO DROP OUT BECAUSE HE
PLAGIARIZED.
JUST A LITTLE ASIDE THERE.
YEAH, REAGAN A, BIDEN D-.
IT’S THE SAME GUY WHO SAID,
QUOTE, YOU CAN’T GO TO A
7/ELEVEN OR A DUNKIN’ DONUTS
UNLESS YOU HAVE A SLIGHT
ACCIDENT.
PICTURE A REPUBLICAN SAYING
THAT, STEVE.
STEVE: AND AFTER JOE BIDEN KIND
OF BOTCHED THE DELIVERY, THEN HE
ATTACKED THE AUDIENCE WITH.
HE SAID YOU’RE A REALLY DULL
CRASS.
>> YEAH.
MEMORIES OF JEB BUSH AND PLEASE